trois épreuves sportives différentes et
2000 participants carton plein pour la
première édition du marathon de Chinon
qui se déroulait dimanche entre ville
médiévale bord de Vienne et paysages de
vignobles un événement sportif donc mais
aussi festif une deuxième édition
l'année prochaine fait d'ailleurs peu de
doute au vu des retours Aurélie Renaud
avoir des jambes et du mental c'est la
base pour courir mais le plus important
ce sont les soutiens et hashinons ils
sont bien là
il faut être là pour les encourager leur
donner à voir à manger voilà on est là
pour eux même ceux que je connais pas
je suis hyper admiratif de tout ce
qu'ils font ce que je ferais pas sur le
parcours des 10 km les athlètes viennent
principalement des environs ces quatre
amis vivent entre Chinon et son Zay ils
ont couru chez eux c'est sûr c'est
symbolique on fait la première édition
c'est dans notre ville donc c'est hyper
plaisant et bah à refaire donc c'est
surtout super convivial puisque c'est un
bah une ville assez justement conviviale
et on connaît du monde et tout le monde
s'encourage et voilà c'est cool la
forteresse domine le parcours les
athlètes sont aussi guidés par la Vienne
et les vignes sur le marathon le semis
et les 10 le parcours est bucolique même
le ravitaillement prend des couleurs
locales c'est la première fois je vois
du vin de Chinon après 10 km et c'est
vraiment le pied
merci on traverse campagne petit chemin
avec des magnifiques demeures et tout
c'est typique chez nous quoi donc c'est
que du bonheur et puis en plus ça va
permettre à certaines personnes de venir
découvrir chez nous qui est quand même
un une belle ville parmi les 2000
coureurs qui ont bravé le vent 700
marathoniens venant de 40 départements
différents le vainqueur de ce tout
premier marathon l'emporte en deux
heures et 31 minutes le champion est
breton c'est vrai qu'il y avait Paris
aujourd'hui mais j'ai fait deux fois je
suis j'ai vu qu'il y avait Chinon je
suis dit pourquoi pas on va tenter je
connais pas cette ville ça a l'air
chouette sinon vous apporter chance
ça change de la Bretagne c'est parce que
c'est pas les mêmes paysages l'année
prochaine les organisateurs comptent
passer de 700 à 1000 marathoniens
[Musique]